now to the second half of my interview
with Attorney General William Bar we
begin this evening from the courtyard of
the Department of Justice by continuing
the conversation about the organized
elements of some of the rioting and
looting bar singled out an Tifa
yesterday but also said authorities are
seeing a quote witch's brew of extremist
groups you know conserve extreme-right
groups trying to look like extreme left
groups we have extreme left groups
masquerading as an extreme right groups
we have players on both sides trying to
spin up violence so it's it's a it's a
complicated situation but you expect
that there'll be more arrests at the
organizing part of it yes soon I can't
put a time limit on these investigations
but I think you know we are very much
focused on getting on top of these
groups turning the page here to the
Durham report and wondering when that is
going to come out you're now a few
months away from an election and there's
some expectation that there's going to
be at least some bombshells in there
about the investigation of the
investigation into Trump College well
you know I can't address expectations I
can't say that even with the disruption
of kovat and the fact that our court
system has essentially been shut down
for a few months
the Durham team has been working very
aggressively to move forward and as I've
also said this isn't being driven by
producing a report we are trying to get
to a point where we can hold accountable
and
one who crossed the line and committed a
criminal violation so that's I think
what you know would be the the the
initial stage of a resolution of
Durham's investigation but I also think
that there will be public disclosure in
some form of reporters at my propria
trum what you've seen crimes have been
committed
well I can't say you know what can you
paint a picture of what it looks like as
far as broad nature of it well I think
you know I think before the election I
think we're concerned about the motive
force behind the very aggressive
investigation that was launched into the
Trump campaign without you know with a
very thin slender read as a basis for it
it seemed that the bureau was sort of
spring-loaded at the end of July to
drive in there and investigate a
campaign and they there really wasn't
much there to do that on and that became
more and more evident as they went by
but they seem to have ignored all the
skull Puteri evidence that was building
up and continued pell-mell to push it
forward so that's one area of concern
the other area of concern is that after
the election even though they were
closing down some of it as we've seen in
the Flynn case and say there's nothing
here for some reason they went right
back at it even at a time where the
evidentiary support or claimed support
like the dossier was falling apart and
it's very hard to understand why they
continued to push and even make public
in testimony that they had an
investigation going when it was becoming
painfully obvious or should have been
obvious to anyone
that there was nothing there you always
get lumped in with being political and
you've pushed back against that the
characterization that you're the
president's attorney but as you get
closer to an election doesn't releasing
this report and making it more at risk
for falling into that political bucket
I'm sure there are people who might say
that I've publicly made clear that this
is not involve looking at President
Obama or Vice President Biden I think
the people that were looking at or not
at that level and I think what names we
would be familiar with some of them but
you know here's the thing for the first
time in American history police
organizations and the national security
organizations were used to spy on a
campaign and there was no basis for it
and the media largely drove that and all
kinds of sensational claims were being
made about the president that could have
affected the election and then later on
in his administration there were actions
taken that really appear to be efforts
to sabotage his campaign and that has to
be looked at and if people want to say
that I'm political because I am looking
at those potential abuses of power so be
it but that's the job of the Attorney
General if you had to characterize the
dirham report as you know it now is it
going to be i opening for americans or
is this can be kind of a blip on the on
the road to I am you know I'm very
troubled by what has been called to my
attention so far but I'm not going to
characterize it beyond that
can you tell us anything about the
investigation to unmasking you know
unmasking is not by itself illegal but
the patterns of unmasking can tell us
something about people's motivations at
any given point of time so we're trying
to take a look at the whole waterfront
on unmasking what was done especially in
2016 and is there criminal implications
there as I say it's not it's not against
the law to to unmask anyone but I mean
for example let's say suppose for a
period in the spring there was a lot of
heavy unmasking done on people involved
with the Trump campaign that would be
very relevant as to what people were
thinking at that time and what their
motivations were you mentioned the Flynn
case you're in the process of trying to
dismiss that charge the charges yet the
judge judge Sullivan continues on and
has now a shadow prosecutor and making a
case that it should continue the
argument is that it's always been
understood that decisions whether pursue
an individual through the prosecution
process or holding them criminally
accountable is vested in the executive
branch and not the courts and he is
essentially in our view trying to set
himself up as an alternative prosecutor
and so have you seen anything like this
before I'm not aware of anything like
this before and I think that's why this
is not being argued at the appellate
stage in the District of Columbia I know
you can't get in specifics but the DOJ
Inspector General identified this top
FBI lawyer who fabricated evidence in
order to justify this warrant against
Carter page to spy on him we know that's
a crime yet there haven't been any
charges yet
is that person still working at the FBI
no and are there charges well you know
we can't discuss you know future charges
but I have to say that I do find a
little irritating you know the
propensity in the American public on
both sides of the political spectrum and
they see something they think could be a
criminal violation I say why hasn't this
person and being indicted again by as in
this person why and you know there's the
old saying that that the wheels of
justice grind slowly drive slow because
we have due process and we follow the
process but people should not draw from
the fact that no action has been taken
that taken yet that that means that
people are people are going to get away
with wrongdoing the president is
counting on you and your department to
crack down on social media platforms for
what he calls censorship including his
own tweets you said the law allows these
companies to operate and it's been
stretched beyond its original intent so
you think these firms are somehow
censoring the president and his
supporters well I think there are
clearly these these entities are now
engaged in censorship and they
originally held themselves out as open
forum where people third parties could
come and express their views and they
built up a tremendous network of
eyeballs they a lot of market power
based on that present presentation
and now they are acting much more like
publishers because they're censoring
particular viewpoints and putting their
own content in there to to diminish the
impact of various people's views so is
there some action that you're taking
well we are looking as many others are
at changing section 230 which is a rule
that provides some protection for these
companies which require Congress which
would require Congress yes prisoner
swaps with Iran have required the
Justice Department to drop charges or
agree to time serve for defendants in
front
quartz is this a good policy when Iran
arrests people for just being American
well it's a policy that you know has to
be handled with care that we don't
invite you know seizing of more
Americans but in the individual cases
where we've done this we felt the
benefit outweighed the risk so it was
worth it yes more to come I can't say
what is it like working with President
Trump in the middle of these crises it's
two in a row now and you've been meeting
with him a lot it's good because I think
the president's very decisive person and
he's interested in hearing all the views
there's a lot of robust discussion and
he makes a decision and I think he's
been a good leader if the president is
re-elected would you serve in a second
term I'm not gonna get into that you're
not but if you ask you would you that
would be presumptuous of me discuss that
our thanks the Attorney General on his
staff